un mensaje muy corto que inició
agradeciendo a los integrantes de la
cámara de los comunes y de los lores los
homenajes que se le han rendido al
trabajo a la vida de la reina isabel en
los últimos días hemos podido escuchar
de diferentes diputados de ex primeros
ministros anécdotas muy personales sobre
la reina isabel segunda que no solamente
enfocan como era como líder pero sobre
todo numerada de personas y su lo que
dicen acá su fantástico sentido del
humor esta ceremonia como ustedes
pudieron ver se realizó en el hall del
parlamento porque el monarca por una
tradición del siglo 17 no puede entrar a
la cámara de los comunes para garantizar
esa independencia frente a la corona y
eso fue lo que hizo el rey carlos
tercero asegurar que él como su madre
seguirá dando ese respeto a la monarquía
y seguirá dando respeto al parlamento
porque es un instrumento fundamental de
la democracia
británica fue un discurso muy corto pero
lleno de sentidos homenajes contando la
importancia que tiene el parlamento para
su madre el 'big ben' la campana gigante
símbolo de londres esa torre donde se
encuentra tiene el nombre de la reina
isabel y fue uno digamos de los regalos
que se le dio en uno de sus jubilados
que marcó un tiempo al frente de la
corona británica y como lo mencionas el
rey carlos tercero viaja a esta hora a
edimburgo donde además de liderar junto
con otros integrantes de la familia real
esa procesión que transportará el cuerpo
de isabel segunda desde el palacio de
holyroodhouse a la catedral de shanghái
el sse también inicia formalmente su
primera gira como monarca para saludar a
los cuatro países del reino unido ahora
luisa hablemos precisamente un poco de
estos preparativos logísticos para el
velatorio de la reina que va a tener
cuatro días no deberá torio en el hall
del parlamento británico donde se
esperan además la asistencia de millones
de personas para dar el último adiós a
la reina
sin duda es la logística y las medidas
de seguridad son enormes probablemente
unos dispositivos que veremos en los
próximos días de seguridad que no
habremos visto nunca en la historia de
este país y eso ya nos da la dimensión
de lo que significará
justamente el velatorio y también el
funeral de estado de isabel segunda que
será en una semana se prevé que en este
velatorio que iniciará el miércoles por
la tarde y se extenderá hasta el lunes
antes del funeral podrían asistir al
menos
750.000 millones de personas no se
podrán tomar fotos no se podrán llevar
flores se calcula que las filas podrían
ser de hasta 20 horas y de 8 km